une pelleteuse des graviers et des
marquages au sol les travaux de
rénovation du cimetière de la verrière
sont lancés depuis un mois un projet
mené par la commune
après plusieurs demandes de la
population est allée n'était pas conçu
pour les personnes âgées et les
personnes handicapées
on revoit toutes les toutes les voix que
l'on peut faire à pied et qu'on pourra
désormais faire en fauteuil roulant
pour des personnes qui ont du mal à se
déplacer cette rénovation des halles est
l'occasion aussi de redonner un nouveau
visage à ce cimetière des années 60 plus
de fleurs plus de gazon et plusieurs
nouveaux aménagements
le monument aux morts va bouger il va
être au bout du cimetière
dans la perspective de l'entrée cette
petite maison là on va y mettre un toit
qui continue avec des fleurs au dessus
et qui va être la nouvelle entrée une
entrée qui sera automatique vous avez à
aller une place et quand tout ça sera
fini on n'aura plus une bonne vingtaine
coût total du projet cinq cent quarante
et un mille euros la moitié financée par
la région 20 % par le département et le
reste par la commune la fin des travaux
est prévue pour le mois de mai première
commémoration célébré dans le nouveau
cimetière
le 8 mai 2019